are we supposed to follow our King and
remain as silent as he you're talking
about the train to a brother you're
talking about treatment what I'm talking
about is freedom freedom crawl kinky
you
holy crap everybody the release and
Inhumans tees are all ready so let's
break this down also try to explain the
crossover with agents of shield the
other TV series in the movies itself
because they did say it's connected to
the MCU but there's still a lot of
questions there's a marvel guardians of
the galaxy giveaway going on right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
is for IMAX gift certificates then
release the teaser poster with the main
cast yesterday you have Gorgon karnak
Black Bolt himself Medusa crystal in
Maximus as the only people speaking in
the trailer where Maximus speaking to
Medusa explaining what his plan is and
going against Black Bolt so it explains
the drama of what season 1 is going to
be it's 8 episodes long so it's closer
to being a miniseries but they says is
there be a military coup now it sounds
like it's going to be led by Maximus
damat so Black Bolt the other royal
family members will be on the outside
trying to retake a tool and by the end
of the season but other than wanting
freedom for all Inhumans we don't know
much about what Maximus is plan is he
might just have some plan to take over
the world
I think they'll try to do something
that's a little more complicated and
grounded than that so we could see a
more legit version of the Terrigen bomb
usually that's the solution you bond the
world with Terrigen gas in the
population of Earth is forced to deal
with it the Inhumans go from being this
really weird group of outsiders to the
majority so they just did the big
Inhumans vs. x-men arc as we learn more
about the plot I'll talk about that
because Fox is doing an x-men TV series
so Inhumans is going to exist by itself
it's not an agents of shield crossover
show it's not a spin-off from that
series either that means you're not
going to see any of the stuff that
shield has been doing for the last four
seasons but the shoulder was kind of
vague about whether or not there'd be
any shield crossover I think they're
open to it if shield can survive we'll
talk about that in a second about agents
of shield making it to season 5 but what
you're seeing beyond this text of the
logo here in the background of this
teaser is at the LAN itself one of the
locations that they were filming was
this giant crater so it looks like
that's going to serve as the crater on
the moon we're at land reside have been
a couple different places it's existed
in the comics more recently at the land
was blown up when Black Bolt detonated
his terrigen bomb at the end of the
Infinity art but they built a new app to
land in New York City that all
got destroyed so the Inhumans aren't
doing so well in the comics right now
but we'll see where they pick up with
them in the series but you can see that
they're obviously all adults black bolts
already been king so it'll be
interesting to see how they weave in
with the MCU because it is connected to
the MCU so we'll see how they reference
the stuff that's been happening in the
movies but they just based on the core
operating mission of the Inhumans just
keep to ourselves they've been watching
what's going on in the MCU but when they
see Ultron is trying to destroy the
earth to destroy the human race they
don't care about stuff like that so they
don't get involved obviously that's
changing now because it sounds like
maximus wants freedom for all Inhumans
so it's going to be a little harder to
stay off the radar if he has some big
takeover plan but there are a couple big
things that you do not see in this
teaser picture here you do not see
lockjaw he's probably going to be mostly
CG that's probably why they didn't put
him in here but he's about this big
standing next to the normal height
people so he is going to be huge the
other one is Triton he's probably going
to be a combination of CG and practical
effects in this human woman who'll be
the audience surrogate she's working in
aerospace
it sounds like based on her description
she finds a clan on the moon because
it's been cloaked this whole time and
gets swept up in their big coup and
that's how the writers are going to
teach all the people that haven't read
comics you know what all the specifics
are how their powers work how their
society works what their history is but
let me know in the comments what kind of
questions you guys have about Inhumans I
know the biggest question is this how is
this going to tie in with all the other
stuff that's going on in the Marvel
Universe on the TV shows the Netflix
series the movies the pitch is that it's
connected to everything including the
movies just because it's so big and
these are supposed to be alias
characters I would say the Inhumans are
closer to being b-list characters
because they've been an analogue of the
x-men in their comic book has never been
as popular as x-men comic book but now
we know based on all the filming they've
done this takes place in present day
it's not like a prequel or anything like
that so just assume that in the movie
timeline Doctor Strange has already
happened Civil Wars already happened by
the time this drops at the end of the
summer spider-man homecoming will
already have dropped but because all the
outdoor sequences they've been filming
are in Hawaii maybe that's where the
series is going to take place sometimes
they just have cities double for other
cities wherever they're filming like
they'll film in Vancouver but it'll
double for some other city for now I'm
just going to assume that it mostly
takes place in Hawaii but obviously at
land stuff looks like it's going to take
place on the moon but as far as I know
there's no Coulson in Episode one
there's no shield characters it's eight
episodes maybe if it does well they'll
do 13 in season two but I think the
reason they're doing fewer episodes is
because the special effects budget is so
high and they want to be able to do
crazy powers as opposed to like shield
that has to work around that you don't
see a lot of special effects on shield
be on stuff like Ghost Rider but we'll
see what they do he's actually coming
back in the finale but what's happening
is is the first two episodes are airing
in IMAX theaters September 1st and then
the rest of the episodes will start
airing September 26 on ABC that's the
same network that airs agents of shield
this is going to be a Tuesday night show
you know agents of shield airs on
Tuesday nights at 10:00 p.m. so I don't
know what time this is going to be on I
don't know how that's going to interact
with everything else it's going to be
crazy because flash is on Tuesday nights
so we'll think of the schedule out when
we get there no worries but I'm a little
pissed off that like everybody decides
to drop their new comic book TV show on
Tuesday nights it was bad enough when
they moved legends of tomorrow to
Tuesday nights so if you know somebody
that works at a TV network just tell
them that you can't put every comic book
TV show on every different network on
the same night it just people won't be
able to watch everything it's going to
take them all week to get through it but
as crazy as all that is like the only
complaints that I have is just the way
that they did this teaser poster does
not do these characters credit it will
look a lot cooler but they haven't added
any special effects to this people are
worried about Medusa's hair just looks
kind of weird wears black both little
tuning fork that helps them harness his
powers on his forehead that by VCG to
who knows if he wears a mask like he
does in the comics there's just a lot
that this doesn't tell you but I am
really excited about Ramsay Bolton being
the villain of this series I think it'll
be a lot of fun I'm not super familiar
with anybody besides Ken Leung but I
think he'll be a lot of fun as Carnac
and the other actors seem like they're
pretty cool too I think there are a lot
of points of failure with this mostly
just because they're not super popular
characters but I think if they can bring
a big enough spectacle people will get
really excited about it and if there's
any special bonus videos that you guys
want me to do for this just let me know
in the comments but because the series
is dropping right after comic-con
happens they'll probably drop the first
real trailer way before that
so you should have to wait too long for
that my next video is going to be
guardians of the galaxy to post-credits
but yesterday was super crazy so if you
think you missed a couple of things that
I posted go to my videos tab just a
double check everything will be right up
here at the top congratulations to wolf
Rex use the latest guardians of the
galaxy giveaway winner please private
message me on the back of my channel so
I can get your contact details while you
wait for new guardians of the galaxy I'm
doing a post-credits video you can click
here for the defenders trailer and you
can click here for my review of
guardians of the galaxy thank you so
much for watching let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you